do you have an influence or you've
always followed how about a professional
athlete well you can now connect with
them
with a new video messaging platform it's
called mentor camp
it's an app that connects people to
well-known experts including former nfl
players
ted speakers top influencers and more it
pairs people looking for personal advice
with
people who are otherwise difficult to
access
we have a lot of very exciting mentors
a part of the mentor cam family and one
being a former olympic
goalkeeper hope solo um which is a very
recognized recognizable name
um we also have an r b singer named
mario barrett
and um
here's how mentor cam works once you
identify which mentor you want to be
paired up with you can tap into the
professional network by reaching out to
them with questions
you can purchase one question or a pack
of five the answers are then sent to you
in a pre-recorded private messaging
service
and those questions range in price
depending on the expert and their field